au pied de la colline des admirateurs du
joueur de basket et des caméras du monde
entier qui scrute les allées et venues
des enquêteurs le site et difficiles
d'accès explique la police de los
angeles à cause du brouillard le bureau
du shérif avait cloué ses hélicoptères
au sol hier matin au moment où celui de
kobe bryant décoller les données de vol
montre qu'il a tourné en rond une
dizaine de minutes à l'ouest de los
angeles avant de s'engager vers la zone
montagneuse voici ce qu'un contrôleur
aérien va dire au pilote l'hélicoptère
perdra encore de l'altitude avant de
s'écraser à flanc de colline il n'y aura
aucun survivant
kobe bryant emmené sa fille de 13 ans
diana un tournoi de basket mais aussi
trois de ses coéquipières et leurs
parents le pilote était qualifié pour
voler dans de mauvaises conditions et
l'appareil est l'un des plus fiables
selon les autorités californiennes
les hommages affluent depuis hier et pas
seulement dans le monde du basket à la
cérémonie des grammys il se déroulait
dans le stade où kobe bryant a joué
pendant des années avec les lakers
dieu j'aurais cabris
[Applaudissements]
des hommages avec des fleurs et des
bougies à l'extérieur du stade
ou même sur les terrains de tennis
d'australie
partout le numéro 8 ou le numéro 24
le magazine time lui consacre une
couverture sobre cette semaine
[Musique]
et les oscars ne manqueront pas de
rappeler qu'il avait gagné le prix du
court métrage en 2018
pour cette adaptation de son poème qui
évoquait la fin de sa carrière
oui
comment
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal